[Musique]
il
après deux éditions annulé le versailles
et jazz festival est de retour en ce
mois de mai plusieurs concerts sont
programmés notamment au palais des
congrès celui de kyle eastwood ce sera
le 21 mai on va en parler avec le
président de ce festival olivier silhol
qui nous a
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
bonjour libeccio bonjour merci de nous
recevoir ici au palais des congrès à
versailles c'est ici que la tête
d'affiche du versailles à jazz festival
qu'elle eastwood va se produire ce sera
le 21 mai sur cette scène nous en dit
plus en quelques mots sur ce rendez vous
après c'est évidemment le rendez vous
phare de notre festival 2022 bien
évidemment avoir une vedette de la
dimension de kyle eastwood et pour nous
à la fois un honneur et une chance mais
mais ça n'est pas tout nous avons à
côtés de kyle eastwood une belle
brochette
d'artistes de de très bon niveau enfin
on va venir on va parler de tout c'est
tous ces artistes qui vont se produire
injuste par rapport à ce concert phare
cette tête d'affiche kyle eastwood fils
de clint bien sûr il s'est fait un
prénom comme compositeur et musicien
notamment pour les abords de son père
que ce soit un stick river million
dollar baby ou encore gran torino et
invictus sur scène ici il va reprendre
quelques musiques de film à la manière
inédite oui en fait une programmation
assez assez ouverte ça va être tout
effet tout à fait intéressant
c'est une grande chance nous quittons
nous d'avoir un contrebassiste de cette
de cette pointure et puis de pouvoir
bénéficier de cette merveilleuse salle
du palais des congrès pour l'accueillir
un écrin digne de lui je dirais
[Musique]
gran torino
ce ne sera pas le seul à se produire
dans le cadre du festival on pourra
aussi découvrir sur scène de new york
blue note qing tête à l'université
ouverte versailles ça ce sera le 20 mai
oui tout est fait alors je suis très
heureux c'est une autre tête d'affiche
pour nous nous avons la chance de
pouvoir faire venir trois grands
solistes de la scène jazz new yorkaise
donc on à dmitry baevsky le saxophoniste
on a le pianiste jobs patton et le
trompettiste jo manière elie qui donc
devant se produire en quintet un quintet
qui s'est déjà produit à new york avec
un grand succès donc j'attends beaucoup
de ceux de ce concert moi je suis
certain qu'il sera de très bon niveau
m
[Musique]
on a évoqué rapidement de tête d'affiche
de concerts qui vont se dérouler à
versailles il y a aussi d'autres villes
qui participent du coup encore jouy en
josas oui ça c'est c'est une ouverture
que nous avons fait déjà depuis un
certain nombre d'années ne pas rester
uniquement sur un sur versailles et
essayé d'associer les communes alentours
nous avons eu toussus-le-noble fontenay
le fleury et depuis déjà plusieurs
années buquet louis en josas qui sont
des partenaires fidèles la programmation
est très riche y avait aussi des rendez
vous pour les enfants pour les plus
jeunes absolument absolument ça nous il
nous y tenons beaucoup nous ne
souhaitons que notre festival puisse
ouvrir au plus large public et même à
celui des enfants parce que les les
enfants sont aussi le public du jazz de
demain et donc nous avons deux concerts
de spectacles concerts spectacles
musicaux il ya ceux ci
l'humour je dirais est là et la musique
et nous espérons bien que les familles
les familles vers sérieuses se
presseront avec leurs rejetons à ces
deux concerts qui ont lieu un mercredi
après-midi et 1 dimanche après midi qui
sont des des jours particulièrement
favorable pour ce public la diversité
des concerts programmés des rendez vous
programmé permet aussi de montrer la
diversité du jazz le jazz est multiple
si on s'attarde un peu cette fois ci non
plus sur la programmation sur le jazz en
lui-même gospel swing sol vocale comme
vous le savez le jazz à de très
nombreuses chapelles et souvent dans ces
chapelles des fanatiques ils sont pas
toujours dans l'inclusion mais justement
notre festival a une double ambition je
dirais depuis son origine c'est à la
fois de satisfaire les amateurs de jazz
et même les plus les plus exigeants et
en même temps d'essayer d'ouvrir le jazz
sur un public qui n'y est pas habitué
comme vous le savez peut-être versailles
est plutôt la capitale de la musique
baroque et plus largement de la musique
classique musique électro aussi en
musique électro effectivement faire les
dépendants de ces versaillais qui ont
fait de grands succès effectivement dans
cette musique là mais donc l'idée c'est
entre le entre le rock et le baroque en
quelque sorte d'essayer de d'introduire
le coin du jazz est de faire découvrir
cette musique qui à la fois le caractère
savants de la musique baroque
et le caractère le plus populaire
de la musique rock évidemment elle le
festival a maintenant une vingtaine
d'années vous avez le sentiment d'avoir
réussi justement ce pari d'imposer le
jazz à ce public versaillais et que des
rondes nous avons réussi à fidéliser
un petit public jeudi un petit public
parce qu'en fait on constate qu
effectivement beaucoup de versailles et
ne connaissent pas encore notre festival
mais pourtant ce n'est pas faute chaque
année de faire du gros efforts de
communication
mais avec le temps on constate quand
même que de plus en plus de versailles
et reviennent et beaucoup de ceux qui
étaient venus pour la première fois au
jazz je dirais à travers notre festival
donc nous avons l'impression que notre
objectif de faire découvrir le jazz et
de le promouvoir finalement à versailles
fonctionne bien il pourrait fonctionner
mieux parce que là encore il ya
certainement des réticences culturelles
ou publiques de classiques souvent ont
tendance à dire ah non le jazz c'est pas
fait pour moi ça ne m'intéresse pas et
sera donc il y as et des résistances
qui met un peu de temps à être réduites
mais on constate que même un progrès
chaque année mais les mariés ça
encourage effectivement les efforts que
nous mettons en oeuvre monsieur nous
sommes une petite association avec une
poignée de bénévoles et vous imaginez
bien que cette organisation présente des
efforts importants pour nous
[Musique]
où
vos ambitions pour la suite de ce
festival alors puisqu'il a maintenant
une vingtaine d'années et comme bien
adultes quelle suite vous allez lui
donner une envergure de communes ou au
contraire
normalement mon ambition reste reste la
même c'est à dire effectivement de faire
venir le le plus de public versailles et
au jazz c'est une vous l'avez compris
c'est une gageure de moins sur le plan
culturel mais nous avons le sentiment
que nous avançons bien sur ce chemin là
nous sommes évidemment intéressé à
associer les communes des environs
puisque
versailles et et est une région c'est
non seulement une ville mais c'est une
raison culturelle il ya autour de
versailles
tout un public potentiel et donc ne nous
souhaitons continuer cela sans pour
autant trop diversifié parce que si nous
avions trop de concerts autour de
versailles nous n'aurions nous n'en
aurions plus assez à l'intérieur de
versailles donc versailles reste quand
même le coeur de notre festival d'autant
plus que notre partenaire central depuis
depuis l'origine c'est là c'est la
mairie de versailles qui nous soutient
très fidèlement et qui est pour nous
véritablement indispensable à notre
existence même mais pas seulement notre
développement vous savez un coup de
coeur en ce moment jazz pour conclure ou
non j'ai du mal à me fixer vous savez je
suis responsable d'une programmation qui
se veut aussi ouverte que possible donc
je n'ai pas de préférence personnelle à
a marqué sur ce terrain là je dirais
merci beaucoup nous avons reçu ici donc
les quelques dates vont s'afficher 1 la
programmation complète est à retrouver
sur votre site internet pour les
réservations également et merci aussi à
vos équipes du palais des congrès qui
nous ont reçus ici à versailles dans ce
magnifique cadre on va donc se produire
l'une des têtes d'affiché qu'elle dise
oui ce sera le 21 mai merci beaucoup de
nous avoir suivis et à bientôt sur tv 78
qui